my name is ash will I work for thought
works as a developer so I've spent a
little about 12 years in the industry I
spent most of my career working on back
in Java and.net applications but over
the last few years I have worked a lot
in front in JavaScript applications
within large enterprises and it's been a
lot of fun working with JavaScript
within the enterprise but at the same
time there are a few lessons that I've
learned that I'd like to share with
y'all the intent is so that when you
take JavaScript into the enterprise you
are more productive within the
enterprise you also reduce risk for an
enterprise and at the same time enjoy
working with JavaScript within the
enterprise so I'm going to be primarily
focusing on three things the first one
is expectations within an enterprise
when it comes to building software and
then I'm going to go over enterprise
planning and the impact of JavaScript
when it comes to planning within an
enterprise and then I'm going to talk
about certain constraints that are
present in large enterprises that can
act as barriers at times so let me start
with the enterprise expectations these
are things that need to be managed well
if not the reality ends up in the
opposite direction at times so the first
one I want to focus on is there's an
expectation within enterprises of
modularization enterprises by the nature
of their size and their geographical
distribution often run similar
businesses in different regions and
there is always high appetite for reuse
within an enterprise an application
built in one place they want the same
look and feel similar experience in
other regions so they want to reuse a
lot of the code that is being used
sometimes these things in large
enterprises are not use case drivel
so if we don't put a thought towards
modularization or we use a bad use case
you can end up with very high costs when
it comes to reuse of your code across
regions and this is something that
enterprises don't like at the same time
if you don't have a proper use case for
this reuse you end up over engineering
the concept of modularization so how do
we r immediate this right so what we can
do is we can try and prepare for this
modularization not overthink it so you
favor building loosely coupled code try
and build modules in JavaScript but at
the same time make sure these modules
communicate with other modules through
events rather than point-to-point
communication for example if you have a
module that logs in that it raised an
event once you're successfully logged in
and people who are interested in that
event can then react that way this code
is much more reusable than coupling your
login module two different modules try
and share your code as widgets rather
than as big modules that have
functionality so these widgets can be
configurable you can have them as
resealable widgets make them responsive
then these widgets can be used in
different applications within an
enterprise at the same time start by
packaging your code so you can share
your code as bower components you can
share them as node modules use a package
manager such as you know npm we heard a
lot about n p.m. today at the same time
within enterprises if you see it's very
difficult to create a module and and
upload it onto the internet into a
public repository this is something that
enterprises wouldn't allow and in this
case it's important that if you want to
do node or power you have an internal
module depository so you can use a tool
such as artifactory and artifactory
supports power and npm so you can upload
your notice your modules to a private
repository within an enterprise so
factor this very early the next thing
I'll focus on is non-functional
requirements
right so within an enterprise we often
underestimate these non functional
requirements there are quite a few of
them and primarily around custom
analytics many enterprises do not allow
their data to be sent out over the
Internet so your access to analytic
tools that are available is less more
often than ever they have solutions for
this different solutions you know paid
solutions running in different parts of
the world so they would like you to
integrate with these solutions
authentication and authorization again
they have third-party software that does
it for them we need to integrate with
this there is always a requirement for a
lot of auditing within an enterprise so
if we don't deal with this early you
often find that we grossly underestimate
the amount of work involved in
non-functional requirements and what we
build is sometimes not reusable across
regions so a few suggestions to
remediate this is try and build your non
functional requirements in a
non-invasive fashion in JavaScript so
you can use similar service head
concepts that you have in Java or.net
you can do aspect-oriented programming
within javascript as well and what this
tends to do is it decouples a lot of
these non functional requirements from
your functional code hence making it
easier to change and it doesn't pollute
your main business functionality right
because these are horizontal concerns
there are many aop frameworks available
I have worked with angular aop primarily
there is meld and aspect chase as well
some of these frameworks also support
promises so you have a handle to send
out data once a promise has been
resolved or rejected right so they have
support for it so try not to build your
own use some of these frameworks and
lastly unit tests your non functional
requirements because these are very hard
to debug because they are instrumented
around your code the next expectation
within enterprises is often metrics and
documentation so enterprise is large
enterprises often have a lot of vendors
that build things for them
and they experience vendor churn so
there is always a risk of losing
knowledge right which is why there is a
lot of emphasis on documentation
sometimes enterprises like to own or
transfer that ownership to themselves
once they feel they are ready to take
over the code at that point they look
out for documentation and there are
always kpi's link towards quality of
what is being generated and it's
important that we build the same kind of
quality metrics into our JavaScript code
that we use for our back-end server side
code as well so if we don't deal with
this early it could result in a lot of
risk to an enterprise and a lot of cost
as well because the knowledge transfer
doesn't happen in an effective way so
there is an expectation for
documentation if we don't have metrics
or tools that can give us metrics on the
kind of quality of the code we are
writing you would end up with poor
quality and the most boring thing that
you will find is having to write a lot
of documentation towards the [ __ ] end
right when a lot of context is lost so
how do we r immediate this start right
at the beginning do not allow this to
pile up towards the end be aware that
this is an expectation within
enterprises choose a JavaScript analysis
tool such as say plateau or sonar aureus
lint and set good thresholds for your
code quality so lot of these tools are
able to analyze your cyclomatic
complexity duplication and structure of
your code and you know the cleanliness
of your code they give you very good
metrics another important thing is
within enterprises there's always a
demand to have a holistic view of your
software quality guide so they have
tools that generate quality reports for
their back-end software they do not want
reports for a front end to be separated
out from the back end so see always
within an enterprise go find out what is
the current tools that are being used
for analysis see if you can integrate
your front-end reports with that so you
get a holistic picture of quality you
could J stock have comments that
document your code or even more fun is
if you can build live documentation that
stays current with
the code that you write so there are
runtimes that allow you to inspect them
and you can generate documentation the
next part I am going to focus on is
enterprise planning many enterprises
budget once a year they budget for an
entire year and they plan for a year's
worth of work and these promises are
then made by the business to their
customers and once that is done you will
find that functional delivery often
takes assumes priority JavaScript world
is a lot of fun but there's also a lot
of churn and this churn could result in
frequent rewrites and this is often
unanticipated when it comes to a
year-long worth of work right and just
to pursue that your long worth of work
if we don't stay on the upgrade path
this is going to increase the cost and
risk of delaying this sorry so how do we
r immediate this situation right so it
would be good if we can prepare for this
churn you know and then protect yourself
from the churn and create a Java Script
decorator within the enterprise so I'll
talk a bit about preparing for this
journal so often front-end code has been
mainly for validation purposes but
things have changed right we are now
using frameworks such as angular or
ember wherein you can have a lot of
logic sitting within the front end now I
think a lot of the programming
principles that apply to back-end code
apply to your front and software as well
so within your MVC framework as well you
can layer your code into controllers
that manage your UI and then you can
have layers of code such as facades that
you know delegate to a service layer
which then talk to your back-end now if
you do not want to couple yourself to a
framework try and keep your facade
services etc and plain old JavaScript
because then it makes it easier to
change because only your controllers
then are coupled to a framework that's
undergoing the chump also try and use
dependency injection for whatever
objects that you build things like xmas
six modules or required a system days
these help you inject dependencies and
makes it much more easy to unit test
your code right and swapping out
dependencies becomes easier once you are
prepared protect yourself as well from
this Joan so favor hi unit test coverage
at the same time try and make sure that
your unit tests are not coupled to the
framework that's undergoing shown
because these are your safety net and if
they break when the framework changes
then you do not have anything to verify
that your code is still doing what it
was supposed to write so and then have
high functional test coverage as well
these often don't tend to make
assumptions of the underlying tech
that's being used so when you change a
framework these tests hopefully
shouldn't change and they can be your
safety net lastly to work well with the
business make sure that you factor the
upgrades for the software choices that
you've made into the plan and plan your
work accordingly make sure you include
your tests and documentation because
these two might change because of the
churn we often tend to miss these out
create a jace TechRadar what does this
radar do this radar would help you
standardize within the enterprise what
frameworks you want to adopt right my
adopt what I mean is these are things
that have worked well with and
enterprise have been very productive
than an enterprise so you continue to
use it within the enterprise trial is
somewhere where you have projects that
can absorb a bit of risk you believe
something will work and you can try it
out then SS is where you're actually
just spiking out with this piece of
software and trying to find out whether
this is going to help within an
enterprise hold is a recommendation that
you're making stop using something
within an enterprise all right so this
helps in bringing about some consistency
in the choice of frameworks because we
are spoiled by choice in the JavaScript
world periodically try and refine this
radar so that it stays current this can
be curated by a group of key people
within the enterprise lastly focus on
enterprise constraints so the first
constraint is the browser ecosystem
now enterprises always want their
software to be supported on all versions
of available process read ie6 not
anymore but I have been in those
situations right and unfortunately some
of these browsers are not even available
within the enterprise so enterprises
have a way of you know installing
software and it's very hard to get the
kind of version that you want and based
on this browser choice the choice of
frameworks that you use might end up
with need for poly filling which we know
is not very performant in browsers such
as I now this could result in high
maintenance and low performance one of
the ways to remediate this is you could
use analytics from applications that
have already been built in the
enterprise to know what is the browser
said that your customers are currently
using use this to drive your technical
choices and make choices where you can
avoid poly filling set up a process for
installing the supported browsers so
that you can deliver in an agile fashion
and you don't know how to have to delay
your testing to the [ __ ] end and lastly
focus on a constraint which is
enterprises have a lockdown environment
when it comes to internet access so it's
often very difficult to just get into an
enterprise and do an NPM install and it
will not work so there is always limited
internet access within an enterprise
there are lengthy software approval
processes for installing any piece of
software this becomes a barrier using
open source and also results in a lot of
loss of productivity so remediation is
prepared for open source as i said
earlier provision and internal package
repository such as artifactory which can
get you your Bower and NPM modules
request for read-only access to github
so that you can install things from the
internet and also a soft and internet
access because for open source to be
successful you need good forum support
I'll finish by talking about the last
constraint which is compliance and
security
with front-end JavaScript applications
some part of your enterprise data now
begins to reside in the browser they
reside in browser caches they could
reside on the disk of the user now if
this is not secure then it could result
in a regulatory violation for
enterprises which can bring a lot of
risk financial risk and reputational
risk to an enterprise so you can
remediate this by setting up a
certification and approval process right
at the beginning make sure that you have
competent people or bodies to certify
that whatever data you are going to be
storing now in the front end is secure
and it is compliant with the policies
that govern the enterprise and also put
in a licence approval process to make
sure that the enterprise is safe from
the kind of software that you are using
we often minify a JavaScript code there
are options to include the licenses and
not have them removed from the software
so just be aware about this so this is
all I have to share with you folks thank
you